hi everyone i'm len
may i am the ceo and co-founder
of endocanna health we're biotech
company
that actually uses your own dna to help
you
with your own experience with
phytocannabinoids
we look at the endocannabinoid system
and help guide you
to an experience that will help avoid
some possible
adverse events so you can have a more
optimal experience
in your overall planar cannabinoid use
but before i even get started i want to
talk about this
mystery of dna and i want to talk about
dna
in a way that somebody who's not a phd
can understand somebody like me
a sciency guy so i'm going to try to
explain it in a way
where we can kind of relate to so it's
sort of my version of dna 101
and the first thing i want to establish
with everyone is that we are
99.9 identical all those things about
we're so
different 99.9 percent but it's a 0.1
percent
that truly makes us unique and truly
makes us different
and that is found in our dna
and our dna is found in every single
cell in our body
and what does that really mean well what
it means is that we have these genes and
there's uh
you know uh there are um
two um two chromosome
uh parts of uh 23 uh there's 23
different chromosomes in two pairs
so that would be 46 total within our
bodies there's hundreds of thousands
of genes and there are segments of dna
so each one of these genes contains uh
protein material that becomes the
building blocks
for everything that we have in our
bodies
so our predispositions to lots of
different things and
you know our hair our organs everything
else
and we inherit them from our parents so
we get two copies from our
our mothers and fathers and the way
that this communication happens is the
instructions are actually in these
nucleotides and these nucleotides the
way i like to explain that
is our computers speak in a binary code
of ones and zeros and then what we have
is
we have a user interface that sits on
top of that
but underneath that is ones and zeros so
our dna
speaks to us in a four letter code a c a
t an a and a g and you can see on the
screen
what those letters stand for the
combination of those letters
make us who we are that's called your
genotype
next is the polymorphism and this is
where the unique 0.1 percent happens
so each dna has a little bit of a
different sequence
and when you have those variations in it
that is called a allele so each variant
has two different possibilities uh to
kind of mutate
or uh or be slightly different which is
called that polymorphism
so i want to explain this in in a way
that everybody can understand so we have
genes that are encoded that aren't
kind of fixed so like uh or our eye
colors
the height that we're gonna be um our
skin color
male pattern baldness like i have but
there's other genes
that are we're encoded for that we
actually have the power within ourselves
to be able to modify the expression of
which is called epigenetics so think
about it this way genetics
are your predisposition so that would be
your roadmap
that would be your gps and actually you
know hitting that pothole
along the way that's your epigenetic uh
that is the expression of that
so through your mindset
through your uh how you uh
the nutrients that you consume in your
body uh and actually phytocannabinoids
they can all control the expression of
those genes so just because you have a
predisposition
it doesn't mean a lot you're locked into
that
so i want to talk about these different
fonts that we have
just to kind of preface oh and i'll
explain what we do
in more detail but these are different
studies
and different observations that we've
had
uh throughout you know the many years of
endocanna health so we can show everyone
the effect of stress and how stress
works within your
body so uh we have a gene called thought
that gene
uh actually uh degrades
uh um anatomite so just
in the general sense an animate is an
endogenous endocannabinoid
that is produced as part of our
endocannabinoid system
and that gene uh provide creates an
enzyme that breaks down
anandamide so anandamide is our bliss
hormone the word anon means bliss
so this is our bliss hormone and usually
uh it's
it's released from many different things
but it's released
specifically in this example to be able
to
alleviate stress when we have a stress
response
so i'm going to explain it this way that
if we have a stressful event there's a
bunch of different
chemicals that are blasted into our
bloodstream we have adrenaline
uh we have dopamine we have cortisol etc
when our bodies actually realize that
there is no lion chasing us in the
jungle
they start releasing endogenous
chemicals
one of them happens to be an andamite so
the goal is to bring you back to
homeostasis and balance
however nearly 53 percent of population
share
genotype that actually has
uh shows more pha than the average
population so the more
faah that you have the less anandamide
that you have because it breaks down
so you are much more prone to long-term
stress
and if that happens then you know people
uh
experience that stress on the basis also
it increases cortisol
which then can be associated with
higher ph levels and inflammation and
pain
so how do you alleviate that well i mean
we found
uh through our studies that there is a
way
to be able to consume a better
cannabinoid terpene profile which i will
get into
uh that is much more effective for
people that have this
genetic predisposition i also want to
talk about
metabolism so this is really really
interesting because
a lot of people when we consume cannabis
especially cbd and thc
our liver uh has different enzymes to
convert
those those cannabinoids of
phytocannabinoids
so thc you know it's converted
to 11 oxy hydroxide delta nine tetra
hydrocannabinol
and then uh there are genes uh they're
called
pharmacokinetic genes uh cytochrome p450
i know it's really sciency but
i'll make sure that i address it in a
way that everybody can understand
so the idea is that everybody
metabolizes different things differently
foods etc and we can genetically
predispose and show people if they are a
poor metabolizer if that's the case
maybe uh they should not consume
something to their first pass
or modify their dosing specifically
based on what type of metabolizer some
people are ultra rapid metabolizers
and they don't need it uh as much
they're really creating
you know what i refer to as expensive
urine for themselves because they
metabolize
and it it screes really quickly so
to show you how how that works
in your body well the gene that we're
looking at
is the cyp2c9 which actually
metabolizes thc
and you can see that over ten percent
of the population share this genotype as
a predisposition
and over fifty percent share the phi
gene so these are
we have these inside of us that we're
actually walking around with
and we can see on that really hard to
reach graph that there are certain
groups
that we're looking at with certain
genetic predispositions that do
better with different types of
cannabinoid interpreting profiles
than other groups and that's the thing
that i wanted to emphasize
as well and i'll go into a little more
detail on that shortly
depressive feelings well i mean we're in
an interesting time right now
so there's a lot of genetic triggers
that are happening
to people with these predispositions
once again
genotype is your predisposition uh it's
your
it's your navigation system and the
expression of that
is actually uh the epigenetics so that's
what really happens
so in data uh we found that uh
this depression where depressive
feelings is higher
in people that have an expression
in cnr1 and cnr2 which are really
associated with once again the amygdala
part of your brain
and the forebrain is really interesting
because it releases these chemicals
uh to be able to control stress and
feelings etc
and there are certain genotypes which
are associated with
those depressive feelings and the action
that we take
including consuming different types of
phytocannabinoids
can actually trigger that expression so
phytocannabinoids and terpenes which
i'll get into
in a minute but just to show you that
nearly 40
of the population shares this specific
genotype on cnr2
this is the rsid which shows you the
location of chromosome
and this is the allele combination that
genotype that i talked about
cc means homozygous so you have the same
exact allele combination of both
now if you look at this that people have
reported
that being triggered with depressive
feelings the association of higher thc
with a primary terpene profile called
mercene
which is found in what we would consider
more
indica dominant chemo bars
that are associated with that sedative
state
so just something to kind of correlate
to your own
consumption the next is insomnia
and by the way insomnia is caused by so
many different factors
those stress and emotional factors are
big factors
associated with insomnia as well but
there are specific
genes and uh you know a handful of them
that we were able to identify that have
a direct
correlation to insomnia and
sleeplessness
like mei meis1
as an example so just to give you an
overview of that
there are nearly 34 of general
population
that share this genotype and what
happens is when people are consuming
higher
thc uh formulations and including
terpene profiles that are
dopamine boosting terpene profiles like
limonene and pinene
which are found mostly as
dominant terpene profiles in what we
would refer to as sativa
dominant hybrids those uh in an
exacerbated way
uh will can trigger that expression of
insomnia so think about it this way as
an analogy
um i use alcohol as an example i'm not a
drinker but just to get
so you can understand if somebody
consumes
uh a lot of alcohol then they can
they can pass out for instance so and
they can sleep
and be in that state for 10 12 hours
when they wake up
they don't feel rested and the reason
why is among many different reasons
because
your body is trying to excrete the
poison of alcohol but
one of the reasons is because you're not
getting a restful sleep so you're
getting that 10
12 hours but there's activity in your
brain so you're an
alpha you're not getting that theta the
rem sleep the really restful sleep
and what happens when people do consume
high amounts of thc
that have this predisposition uh with
that terpene profile
that's the activation of their brain in
the forefront of their brain is
happening while they sleep so never
getting that restful
sleep so how do you know all these
things and what can you do
to be able to mitigate the expression of
these genes
well i'm going to dive in a little bit
into more of what we do
uh specifically and to kind of give an
example but before i do that
i want to show you that the
this is the information that we've been
able to learn and gather so far
and what i what this chart shows is
these are the
genetic predispositions that people
actually consume
cannabis for of phytocannabinoids and
this is the
amount of the population that has
these genetic predispositions that can
be triggered
by a phytocannabinoid so think about
this way
you know over 50 percent of the general
population
have predispositions to stress uh than
the impulsivity
uh also opioid dependence over sixty
percent of the people
have a genetic predisposition so think
about it healthcare professionals
if you have somebody that can you can
show
up front that they have a predisposition
of opioid dependence
maybe avoid you know prescribing opioids
and suggest a cannabinoid formulation
instead
phytocannabinoids understanding your
specific genetic predisposition
and where you fall in can help guide the
experience
and can avoid this negative
adverse event like a psychosis a
psychotic-like
effect which is somewhere around 50 of
general population has
so understanding that and guiding you to
that experience
that's really really important so is
there a way
uh and there is a way and we want to
work with
uh healthcare practitioners and also
uh general population uh there is a way
we've launched our company in 2017
with thousands of people that have taken
a dna test
and i'll show you how it sort of works
so you can look to see
what you can do to the overall goal is
to personalize
your overall experience and that's the
goal with everything we do
because everything is personal including
cannabis
and consuming what it is that's more
geared as
precision therapeutics for yourself is
the way
of the future so how does it work
is we have a dna test
and we have a full hippa compliant
portal
called my dna live so my dna live
allows us to use our test and we have
a test called endodna which you would
swab inside your mouth
you would register that test because
it's fully hipaa complying
fully anonymized and you would ship it
to our lab will genetically sequence
that
and then we'll send you an email that
your report is ready when you log into
your secure portal
you'll see this first so we'll show you
color-coded
whether you have genetic predispositions
to those symptomatic conditions
and then it'll guide you through the
process so it's color-coded
green means there's no genetic
predisposition so there's no real risk
associated with genotyping yellow means
there's a variant
there's one so there's a slight risk and
then
red means there's multiple variants
detected so it's an exponentially higher
risk
it also looks a drug to drug interaction
so somebody's taking prescription
medication
uh looking to see what prescription
medication they're consuming there's a
full database
and if you uh need to modify us
some cannabinoids can actually inhibit
the efficacy of prescription
medication some can accelerate
exacerbate that
so understanding that and how to consume
correctly and then there is a survey
that allows us to look at a baseline and
a feedback loop
mechanism so we actually understand
better through
deep learning on what other suggestions
we can make for people based on our
genotypes
the next is what your report looks like
so this is really really
important because every single thing in
our reports
has a peer-reviewed reference uh we
compare that to others and that's
multiple calories the peer review
reference
is that blue hyperlink underneath the
report so this one says
that john is more prone to depressive
feelings uh this is the name the study
there's a hyperlink to a pubmed study
you can also see how you can compare
yourself to other genealogy
or other genetic
groups so if you're if your ancestry
is from you know southeast asia uh
versus uh
eastern versus europe you can see how
that
genotype is compared on the screen
that's the oval
that's on the bottom right underneath
the hyperlink
so the idea is that
this is you have lifelong updates
because
we're involved in studies there's many
of you and other people who are involved
in studies so studies become available
uh our artificial intelligence pulls
that in
we have a science team or group an
advisory group which i'll share with you
that we make a determination which
studies actually
uh go into our research and what we
point to so as new studies become
available
especially minor cannabinoid studies
they will be included
in in this as well the next is
ratio suggestions so what people want to
know is
they want to know uh what they should
consume
how much they should consume and where
do you get it and those are the answers
uh those are the questions that we're
answering with
uh what we do so the uh one thing is we
talk about the ratio of cannabinoids
uh cbd or thc uh when somebody
answers their survey we can see what
their
what they're feeling in the moment and a
home in
a suggestion much more closer uh to what
it is if somebody
has has never taken thc and like
somebody like my mom
she can start with a 20 to 1 ratio and
titrate her way down
or answer the survey questions so we'll
have a better understanding
of her specific experience with thc
the other thing is terpine profiles
which is the secret sauce
of these formulations to find the right
primary and secondary terpene tertiary e
to guide somebody's experience once
again everything here
has a reference that you can see in blue
underneath that so it's really really
important to understand that's the ratio
that's more specific to you
based on a systematic condition the next
is your personalized business plan so
the personal science wellness plan
is condition specific and what i mean
about condition specific
it is it looks at all the symptomatic
conditions
that you have an elevated risk for then
it combines
your answers to your survey questions
and shows you your own personalized
suggestion formulation that is clear to
you based on the symptomatic condition
that you're trying to address in the
moment
so when you look at this here's a
question to make past
uh okay well can you just give me one
single foundation
give me one thing that's gonna address
all my needs
and the answer is there's no such thing
in therapeutic semester there's not one
it depends
what is he trying to address in the
moment so if have a predisposition to
insomnia
we will share that with you however if
you're not experiencing insomnia
that's something that is good to know
about yourself and maybe you can do
something about it
when that expresses itself which is
called epigenetics
however in the moment you're trying to
address
you know inflammation or stress so that
will be the first
information that's provided to you in
your personalized wellness plan
the other thing that you can use the
personalized wellness plan is to see
what it is that you're experiencing in
different times of day
so an analogy could be sort of your
nyquil
and your dayquil type of formulation so
maybe you have a daytime formulation
that is more associated with the lack of
focus that you're experiencing
and that's your formulation to address
that specific need
and then you have a nighttime
formulation that's helping you to
unwind and get more relaxed and even
help with some of the insomnia markers
so
nikon decol hopefully you don't take
your night call during the day
and you should be fine so this is enough
information for you to be able to go to
a dispensary
care professional depending where you
reside in the world
and canada you can go to the
national the country's website and get
those
formulations delivered you just have to
look to see what the ratio
of cannabinoids and terpenes are and
then find that matching formulation
which is good however we step further
and what we do is we use another one of
patent
algorithms to be able to guide people
into
an what we call an endo-line formulation
so the reason why we do this is we
look at certificates of analysis from
all kinds of different companies
for their products and what we do is we
run that through an
algorithm that is associated with your
suggested ratio and we can show you
how closely that product matches your
suggested ratio
and if it's a product that's point three
percent thc or less
in the us at least uh you can go to
their website
and get the product shipped to you
however if you
uh if the product is 0.3 thc or more
you will go to the manufacturer's
website put your zip code
and it'll show you the dispensary or
wherever the outlet is
that's geofence closest to you so you
can find a product
that's closest matching to you to your
genetic predispositions
that's um that's located within
a distance that's closest to you as well
so
basically the idea is to be able to
start with your genetics your genotype
all the way through to a suggested
product
that is a matching endoline product that
gives us a feedback loop for
the users of these products that we
learn from
and we're able to make better
suggestions for individuals
so truly truly what we call
endocompatibility and just to summarize
what i was saying is
the ideas provide the most ideal ratio
for specific genotypes
uncover also the method of delivery so
your modality being a poor metabolizer
maybe avoid
your first pass so having a method of
consumption
is also really really effective and
also dosing based on your metabolic
function
which terpenes and cannabinoids are best
suited for you what you may want to
avoid
and then also we talk about specific
products and the last thing that's not
on the slide
that i also mentioned but i want to
emphasize that
drug to drug interaction it's really
really important
and just to give an example uh there's
there's
one example we just recently had with a
with a
consumer or somebody who works uh with
our product
they were they have a diagnosis where
their doctor suggested
or recommended they use cannabis so this
person
went and uh to a dispensary
this is a woman who's around 80 years
old and she was
told to take gummies by uh the person
working
at a dispensary so i think they were 10
milligram gummies
she won didn't feel anything waited
still didn't feel anything took another
didn't feel anything
and she proceeded to you know consume a
uh
a larger dose of these uh gummies
without any effect so when
she went into her profile and uploaded
her prescription medication
there was a specific prescription
medication
that was an inducer
of uh that thc was an inducer of
that uh cannabinoid uh thc so basically
what what was what was happening it was
that
she had to take 400 times
the suggested dose of thc in order for
her to have that experience to actually
feel that
which is a you know ridiculous amount so
i should have known this up front
maybe she can stagger her medication etc
but this is would be able to guide
somebody in their experience with their
prescription medication
and also other medications
that they want to consume the idea
overall
is to have a an observational study so
what we're doing on an ongoing basis
is learning so we're always learning uh
the efficacy of different products
and how they work with specific
individuals
how do we do that we are committed to
research
so right now we have
three institutional review board
clinical studies that are underway
we just finished our um
our third one right now we have three
more underway
uh which is for a specific condition the
interesting
uh findings in the study are that we
found
in our cohort us a
i think somewhere around 70 percent over
the cohort
had a genotype pattern a genetic pattern
there was specific to our cohort not the
controls
there that are found in like i said
close to 70 percent of our cohort
that are found in 0.2 percent of the
general population
which is uh we'll be publishing that
soon but basically
this is the way that it sort of works is
we're looking
at unique patterns why people are
experiencing certain things that they
experience
some people have these perfect storms
one more example is we had a a person
that was
a poor metabolizer that was uh
so cyp2c9 poor metabolizer
consumed an edible that edible also
triggered
a more of a stress reactivity gene which
was associated with cnr1 and
pha including ptsd so not only
were they stress in the moment they were
also
experiencing that stress that they may
have had you know a year or two ago
there was replay in their brain then
there's a third
gene that was triggered which is akt1
the expression of that
was triggered and they had a a psychotic
episode
and this is rare and i don't want to
scare anybody into you know cannabis is
is extremely safe comparatively to any
other
substance plant medicines plant
therapeutics however
there are certain people that take in
something that's
incorrect for them for their genotype
can actually have
a negative expression so this is
something that's really really
important for you to understand
the other thing is that we use
technology
well at the end of the day we are a
technology company biotech company
so we're heavily invested in
deep learning and the way that we do
this is through
a collaborative effort with our
customers
and this feedback loop is really really
important because
it's the data is fully anonymized so we
are getting data so everybody knows on
record
but the data is not len may's personal
information
that information is encrypted and
anonymized and we're hipaa compliant
it's having a thousand people
that have a similar genotype that have
consumed a similar
formulation in a similar modality
and had an effect that was positive
or that was negative so we're
documenting that and we're looking at
those
so we can learn much more the other
thing that we talked about
is uh studies so as
we include more of our studies as you
out there the researchers the healthcare
professionals
anybody that's involved in studies we
welcome those please continue to do
those
because what we do is we use technology
pull those studies
in and be able to guide somebody
into their personal experience with
those studies so now that we do that
we don't the the technology doesn't make
the ultimate decision
but we have a board
so our science board includes dr ethan
russo
uh dr chris spooner dr mike tagan
and that guy at the end who's just
carries
their lunch for them basically but we we
make a decision
when we pull studies in we make a
decision which studies
should be included or not so if there's
a study of you know 10 men between the
ages of 35 to 40
and a certain country that hadn't
experienced that study will probably not
be included
in our findings so at the end of the day
uh i wanted to thank everybody here for
listening to
my rants i just want to summarize in
this way
cannabis is personal everything is
personal to your body
your dna is the blueprint it shows you
the things that you may want to avoid
and things that you want to consume more
of
including not just cannabis but we look
at the endocannabinoid
system so we look at nutrients things
that may affect your endocannabinoid
system we look at vitamin deficiencies
things may uh affect your
endocannabinoid system and then
phytocannabinoids
look in your endogenous and economics
where you may have some deficiencies
so at the end of the day you can find
what's right for you
and have a much more optimal experience
thank you so much appreciate everybody's
time